nous avons préparé une surprise pour
daniel à l'occasion de son anniversaire
je vous donne pas votre âge ne donne pas
d'un 10/10 juste que si on met toutes
les bougies sur un gâteau le gâteau
risque de s'affaisser un petit peu non
alors vous allez voir ce soir on a
décidé que vous ne repartirez pas vous
ne repartirez pas tout seul vous
connaissez le bachelor oui vous allez
avoir des prétendants ce soir ils sont
magnifiques
gilles maxime et jean-michel non pas lui
qui joue pas jean-luc fau tour à tour
fait une déclaration d'amour et vous
déciderez à qui vous donnerez cette rose
symbole de votre amour
[Musique]
alors je vous rappelle celui à qui vous
donneraient la rose vous repartez avec
lui ce soir
dacca le premier prétendant c'est maxime
[Applaudissements]
daniel sais tu que ton père est un
voleur il a pris les deux plus belles
étoiles du ciel pour en faire tes yeux
moi je suis un couturier je prends le
ciel tout entier pour en faire un
puncheur chantier c'est un amour qui
veulent pita qui palpite plus fort un
humour pas piquée des hannetons france
accueillis dont daniel des com destiné à
comme amour haine comme nous eacom issy
les moulineaux où nous louerons un
chalet comme éternité l comme los teques
sommes tristes comme loeb encore parce
que j'ai pas trouvé d'autre mot et eux
comme et l'ins une chanson unis merci
merci
mais c'est pas d'influencé vous êtes
sensible à ce genre de personnage et ce
genre de visite n'y avait pas piquée des
hannetons donc un petit peu voyez le
côté enfin l'amour et j'aime bien alors
on raison le rétro avec gilles verdez
mais à la fin c'est que les journalistes
sportifs mais je suis aussi un grand
romantique alors je t'ai écrit un poème
footballistique de l'amour je te donne
j'arrête pas je la joue comme si dan je
peux montrer les dents comme didier
deschamps tacler l'adversité comme un
rouleau quand et si un mec c'est beau
c'est un mec fait chaud c'est un mec
veut toucher matériel bourreau alors
émoustillé serait tombé le soir tard je
serai ton haiba et holiday viennent je
serai cavani et si j'ai un coup de mou
j'appelle raid 0 vous voyez ce qui s'est
passé après la partie là cette fois
c'est moi qui change en offrant le même
niveau là c'est là son bracelet
électronique en mode manuel
brassens chantait quand je pense à
fernande je bande est bien quand je
pense à daniel je fait des étincelles
comme toi je suis du signe du scorpion
d'ailleurs j'ai le dard au diapason la
justice d'être éloigné de toi ma miss je
n'ai plus de 100 dans la tête
tout est parti dans mes gambettes vient
apaiser mon coeur en mousse pour toi je
virais mais bourse veut dire que je te
ferai faire un cadeau parce que je
t'aime daniel mans
[Applaudissements]
contact il va alors dernier j'ai bien
aimé toucher parce que ça palpite est
vraiment chez maxi banyala est-ce que
vous avez été convaincu par l'un des
trois c'est difficile parce que j'aurais
pris une petite pincée de chaque année
parce qu'on me dit ali ça c'est pas
possible de mélanger les trains on me
dit qu'il ya un quatrième concurrent un
candidat qui s'est déclaré spontanément
je sais pas qui c est ce qui peut venir
spontanément
est ce qu'ils peuvent être les bons
jours vous vous appelez comment sofiane
sofianh alors est-ce que vous avez un
poème pour daniel moi je suis plus un
poème parce que j'ai rien à vous dire
mais par contre j'ai quelque chose à
vous faire
[Applaudissements]
d
/
à
c
[Applaudissements]
rires ce rapport certaine souplesse
ça va les émotions
ces quatre propositions très différentes
faire aussi nous sommes très dur avec
celui que vous choisissez et on va
savoir un peu plus sur ce que vous aimez
chez les hommes partant pour le dernier
bah j'aime bien aller vers l'inconnu
rendez vous en terre inconnue donc
[Applaudissements]